today we'll discuss how lowe's built
an enterprise class centralized price
management solution
on google cloud platform
my name is vikas saini and i'm an
enterprise cloud architect at google
cloud
joining me today for this session is the
vice president of merchandising
technology
at lowe's companies ron baker
thank you for joining ron how are you
doing today
hey vic os uh doing very well uh
excited to be here today and share what
we've been working on in our pricing
space
and how we're investing and really
advancing our technology so
should be a great session and looking
forward to it
great uh so ron before we start can you
share some information about lowe's
with us absolutely you know lowe's is a
you know very exciting company uh you
know
over overall one of the top fortune 50
companies with stores
in both the us and canada and you know
we have a global workforce
as well and one thing that really
excites me
about lowe's just the investment that
we're continuing to make in technology
and how technology is really you know
key to helping the company to
achieve our goals and i feel
very blessed to be leading both our
product engineering
teams for the merchandise technology
portfolio
just a lot of great things going on and
you know as we're going to talk today
about pricing just one of many areas
that we're
continuing to invest in and you know we
continue to seek
and hire top technology talent as well
and you know we're expanding in
both our us and bangalore locations so
technology has just
never been more exciting than now within
lowe's and
it's a great journey to be on you know
one other thing i'll call out is that
we're in our
second year of a multi-year technology
transformation
and we're building a lowe's tech hub and
right here in charlotte north carolina
so a lot of growth going on and
looking to hire you know close to 2000
additional
technologists you know for that facility
and
just excited about the the growth and
the opportunity that we have
go on here within lowe's
yeah no i agree lowe's is a very
exciting company
and we are very thankful for the
partnership
so let's look at the agenda for today so
we'll briefly discuss the centralized
price
use case go over the solution that was
created
for this use case uh we'll also talk
about the benefits that lowe's was able
to achieve
after implementing the solution we'll
briefly touch the roadmap for the next
phase of the solution and then finally
we'll wrap up so let's start with the
use case overview
surround i'll ask you this can you
please tell us about the use case
and any pain points that you are trying
to address with this solution
yeah let's uh i'll kind of walk through
it uh
in three main areas as you can imagine
vic vicos for a company our size a
number of products
the channels that we serve the customers
that we serve
you know pricing is a extremely complex
area
and you know we we had to start off with
uh we had this challenge where we had
multiple source of truth for our prices
and you know this created a lot of
issues with just how we were managing
across the various channels and so we
had to
spend some time to really understand
that complexity and we knew we needed a
single source of truth
to really take us you know to where we
wanted to be and managing this more
effectively
the second thing is we needed to really
put together
better visibility and controls in place
so that
you know we're more consistent with our
prices and how those prices are set up
across all the channels
that was another significant gap that we
had as we were looking at
just some of these use cases and the
challenges that were in front of us
the third is really around you know we
had to improve how we execute our price
changes
we needed to leverage a single source of
truth but then
take that to the next level in terms of
how do we execute
more effectively and really getting the
right prices in the right place at the
right time
as you can imagine speed was really the
key here right how do we do that in the
most effective way
to really take us to where we needed to
be
so as we went through understood these
challenges
these are really foundational to trying
to determine what's the right technology
that we choose and you know my hat's off
to
our product management organization and
working with our business partners to
really outline these challenges in a way
that our technology teams
could really take these and determine
what is the right
technology solution that we need in
order to enable this and when you look
at the complexity of the business
you know with our prices as mentioned
before
this this is a difficult task that we
had in front of us and
uh we were you know really diving in to
understand these challenges and figure
out
how do we move forward uh to solving
them
in the most effective way it's a very
interesting use case
so let me ask you this why did you
choose google cloud
as a platform for this solution yeah you
know our our team uh
really stepped back when we were looking
at again these use cases and the
challenges that we had in front of us
and we went through an evaluation
of various technologies and one thing
that
is really part of our culture is we go
through
proof of concepts and in this case
we actually ran uh two things in
parallel we were
looking at all open source technology
and then we were looking at uh some of
the components within google cloud
to really kind of test this out and see
how does the technology really help us
to solve the business problem and in the
most you know
effective way and so the teams
did this very rapidly went through these
proof of concepts
and you know this is uh just culturally
what we do
as an organization to ensure that what
we're selecting is the most effective
and so we ended up selecting google
cloud and and really
three main reasons that i'll describe
here of
of why we did that first you got to
think about
having the right architecture that
enabled flexibility
was key behind this and when you take a
something like pricing which is a very
very critical component to your retail
business
and looking at how you scale that we
need the right architecture and
flexibility
to enable us to do that that was that
was number one
number two you know leveraging some of
google's managed services like
spanner and pub sub was another key
element to this and
you know one of the things that when we
look at our engineering team we want to
make sure that
we're building and delivering new
capabilities for the business
as much as possible and by leveraging
spanner pub sub you know we didn't have
to spend a lot of time on and worry
about having to upgrade the underlying
technology you know to to support the
the overall solution so it really
enabled our engineers to focus on
building out these capabilities and
driving value for the business which is
what we want
the third thing i'll call out is around
some of the
you know analytics and by having our
data in a more
centralized location and solution
we're able to get a lot more valuable
insights into
just how we're performing and where we
at in the life cycle and so
that that was really uh the third area
that
was key for us and understanding that
performance
and how we take immediate action is
really what
helped us to make that decision and
google was really
uh you know key to helping us get there
as soon as possible
so again i'll just say hats off to
our engineering teams and and the google
team you know partnering together
uh to get us uh uh to to this point and
helping us
as we made this selection to really uh
move us forward in the most
uh effective why
all right so you heard from ron on the
use case and the pain points
now let's discuss the solution that was
built to solve this
so this solution is built leveraging
some of the technology from a retail
common services platform
so before showing you the actual
architectural i'll quickly go over
some of the design principles for this
solution
one of the key architecture principle of
the solution
is that it's completely event-based
architecture
so most of the traditional architectures
are batch based
all of the upstream events are actually
written to the central event source
so as you would expect the event source
has to be highly available
this event source then publishes events
for other downstream systems to use
you're also able to filter the events
into a central system for fast querying
from other applications
that need access to this data
in parallel you can also load the events
from the system
for analytics and learning and analysis
so if you want to give access to data
for your data engineering team
or your data science team to build
models to do any sort of analysis
reporting they're able to do that
without affecting the core system
and lastly is you can also play back the
events from the archive
if needed so if you ever need to go back
and look
at the chronological order of events how
they occur
you're able to do that with the with the
system so let's look at the architecture
so this slide shows the architecture for
the solution
so as you'll see there's a lot of detail
here i'll go over some of the key
components at a very high level
the first step is price optimization so
this is where we classify price for
items such as base price markdown price
discounts etc so as you would expect
every item
or every sku needs to have a price
optimization
process after the price optimization the
next step
is a data transformation so etl if you
will
so we use a data flow for data
transformation and we also have like a
parser to format and
parse the data once the data is
transformed
it is ingested into cloud spanner so
cloud spanner has the benefit
of true time and what that means is that
easily lets you add a globally
consistent timestamp
for all of your events so the benefit
for the solution is that
this establishes a ground truth of the
order of
all of your messages for all time this
means that you can make downstream
assumptions
anchored on that ground tooth which
solves a lot of complexity for dependent
systems
and services up next are the event-based
triggers
that pull this data into the messaging
queue from
cloud spanner and our messaging queue is
cloud pub sub
so this is the layer where the records
are filtered and written
to a centralized messaging queue pops up
and the benefit of this is that the
multiple subscribers can be registered
to get data from this messaging
publishing queue one of the main
subscribers
is the master publish view the data
or the events are loaded to a
corresponding low latency database
or materialized view for easy query
access
this has to be like a really low latency
database so think of it like an
in-memory database or a really low
latency
nosql database it just depends on the
size of the database
we've actually tested this pattern for
millions of records
and millions of products and this holds
pretty well and one of the main reasons
why we're able to do that
is because we are able to separate the
writes from the reads in parallel you
also have the archiver
which writes these events to a global
archive called the cloud storage
in a compressed state and then
corresponding to the archiver is a
replayer
so replayer then reads the records in
order of the long-term storage
and then decompresses them and loads
them into a new club club stream so if
you ever need to go back
and look how the events were loaded into
the system how you got certain data
was a chronological order of all the
events you're able to easily do that
with the
replayer and lastly we also have the
ability to make
one-off price changes using the price ui
this price ui goes through the
centralized api
and writes the information into cloud
spanner and once the information is in
cloud spanner it goes through the same
process
of pushing the data to master publish
view and to the archiver that we just
discussed
so hopefully this gives you an overview
of the solution that was created to
solve this use case
all right so let's move on to the
benefits of the solution
saron let me ask you this now that the
solution is live
can you please hear some of the benefits
that you've seen so far
absolutely you know the the first thing
uh
that we accomplished was really getting
that centralized view of all the
key components for pricing for all
channels and
as i mentioned earlier guys that was one
of the the challenges we had of just
trying to manage this across multiple
systems and
getting that single view uh was
absolutely key to us
and and achieving that benefit the
second
is increasing our speed to market for
you know the price changes and enabling
just
a lot more efficiencies for how we're
making those changes
you know again you go across multiple
systems
it takes a lot of time takes a lot of
coordination and getting us centralized
improves our speed to market so we can
do that much more effectively
and then a third that i'll call out is
really around the ability to be
proactive and
you know just managing our price changes
and you know knowing that our price
changes have been executed
as you can imagine our store associates
you know they're dealing with a lot uh
in the stores just making sure they're
serving customers so when
we're thinking about the pricing and how
we sent our prices down to stores to
execute we want that to be
as efficient as possible and one of the
key benefits here is it's made us a lot
more effective with how we
you know prioritize those changes and
and how much we're sending
down to our stores so that they can be
more effective at
implementing the necessary prices that
we actually need so
just a tremendous uh progress here and
uh definitely
you know getting a lot of benefit out of
the capabilities that have been put in
place
so now that you're getting all these
benefits ron what are your plans for
the new features and functionalities
that you are looking to add to the
solution as we move forward
yeah you know we're going to spend some
time uh you know focused on
uh really these these three main areas
i'll walk through first is
uh around our price performance and
some of our price change analytics you
know when we look at the
number of price changes and how those
prices are performing in the markets you
know how our customers are responding
that's one area that we want to continue
to build out
and enhance more for the overall
solution
the second area is around price
governance and
some of the audit capabilities again
i'll reflect back to
some of the complexities we had with
multiple systems
and you know how do we have the right
visibility the
number of users that can make changes to
our prices you know it was very complex
and
very difficult to manage and so this
foundation we have in place now
is really positioned as well so that we
can
more effectively track and and control
how those prices are are handled so
we'll continue to enhance that
functionality
as we move forward and then the third
area that i would call out just around
you know price testing and measurement
and you know how we put
our prices in market and getting the
results back
and and measuring the effectiveness of
that is absolutely key and
uh we'll we'll leverage this foundation
in place to build upon
so that we get more effective
measurement and understand how we're
progressing
going forward so ultimately we want to
ensure that we're
you know putting forward the the best
price you know for our customers
at the right time at the right channel
and uh the foundation we now have in
place
is uh going to be key to helping us
continue that
priority in that journey all right so as
you heard from ron
this pattern provides many important
benefits over traditional architecture
so the first one is a global consistency
so cloud spanner has the benefit of true
time so it
easily lets you add a globally
consistent timestamp for each of your
events
so this establishes a ground truth of
the order for all of your messages at
all time
and you can have your downstream systems
work with that assumption
which is a huge benefit and solves a lot
of complexity for those downstream
systems
the next one is high availability
so multi-region rights are necessary for
systems that run in multiple places
east or west you know disaster recovery
but multi-region
rights are also great for sending events
from a single system in the data center
to multiple systems that run in the
stores
in this example or vice versa so for
things like price
inventory tracking real-time sales
metrics
this is uh important to have high
availability across the board
and as you mentioned earlier we've
actually tested this solution
for millions and millions of products
across channel
and the solution holds pretty well so if
you have some
very stringent slas and you want to make
sure that the performance doesn't
degrade when you're using millions of
millions of record then
this solution is probably the right one
for you and then as ron mentioned
earlier as well
is um this lets you focus
on these strategic tasks and the dev
teams
are focused on building business logic
or the business value directly
associated with the use case
and not worry about some of the
operational tasks of keeping the servers
up scaling them up or down because the
system takes care of that
this results in quicker time to market
and much lower total cost of ownership
for the solution
i want to again thank ron baker vice
president of merchandising technology at
lowe's companies
for sharing the information and his
thoughts with us
and to you uh thank you for listening to
our presentation
hope you found the content useful i just
want to say
add to that vikas uh you know thanks for
the partnership here with
google and you know really appreciate
the opportunity to speak
to what we've been able to accomplish
here in the pricing area you know like i
mentioned
uh an introduction you know lowe's
advancing our business
with technology like never before and
i'm excited to see
so many capabilities like pricing you
know enabled and proud of what our teams
have been able to accomplish
with this modern technology so i hope
all of you
as well got some valuable insights into
the content
and i want to thank all of you for your
time today